[Music]
I've known your brother James for a
while and he's doing some odd stuff now
posting selfies on social media right
and I know that we're not supposed to
answer for our brothers action you're
sure but I'm gonna make you answer for
your brother's accident you know I saw
him a couple of weeks ago and I didn't
get into this with him but you're here
now look at this look at who's posting
out there now what's what's he what's he
doing it's a good question um you know
I'm not on social media so I wasn't made
aware of this until I was actually doing
the junket for this movie and I don't
know I mean compared to like some of the
other weird things he's doing this seems
like kind of a refined act you know you
feel like he's pulling it in a little
bit a little bit ask you about this he
he posted a picture of that he drew of
Seth Rogen naked that's all over the
Internet right he had to pixel out your
major portion of it right right this was
another thing that was brought to my
attention during this press tour and a
lot of like multiple people asked me if
I was jealous that he didn't paint me
like that and I think that I don't know
we would have to have a family therapy
session immediately if he was painting
me nude I was like the the most tasteful
one he did like there's other ones where
says legs are over his head with things
just dangling everywhere yeah so this
kind of way to stop your brother from
doing this or is this gonna is he going
to continue in this vein for a while
again as I said like dignified for him
[Laughter]